hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
friends is one of my all-time favorite
shows you know what
take it back it's my favorite show of
all time they're one of our top reward
tiers on patreon whatever video you
request we must definitely do and put up
on the youtubes and today comes from
Michael B it was asked for a video for
us to cover and I'm very excited to
check out comes from Screen Rant called
friends pitch meeting I'm assuming it's
one of their joke videos no this is the
actual pitch meeting they had a camera
there all the way back then comedy
stopping jokes that are gonna keep
making some joke no that's just the one
I thought you're gonna succinct joke I
paid attention every single note that
you gave me on camera joke form I take
very seriously and applied in my life
okay all jokes now will be 5 to 10 words
long and that's yeah so it's called
friends a group of people that are
friends right but like what's their deal
well they're all friends together where
the characters though the France yeah
but why them well the title of the show
is friends so obviously we're gonna
follow the friends follow anyone else
friends yeah just friends stuff it's
fine so there's a group of friends yes
how old are they the friends the friends
yes how old are the friends they're like
in their mid-20s okay good that's
helpful
great so they do like typical mid-20
stuff exactly they're just like every
group of friends in their mid-twenties
so relatable yeah like one of them is a
paleontologist named Ross what when
people are in their twenties there's
always one of the group who's like a
paleontologist does does that happen
yeah I think that's okay
will be an interesting character he's
the boring one oh yeah he's gonna have
this thing with Rachel over the span of
several seasons Rachel yeah Peter she's
literally just run away from her own
wedding because she realized she's not
attracted to her fiance she thinks he
looks like mr. Potato Head oh my god
that's horrible
yes she's not the best person isn't that
gonna be tough to get people to want to
follow a character like that actually
super easy barely an inconvenience oh
sure well I figure she could like never
wear a bra should be so anyway Rachel's
gonna move into Monica's apartment
without asking permission who's Monica
Monica is Ross's sister
so Rachel must be like really good
friends with Monica for that to happen
they haven't spoken in years and Monica
wasn't invited to Rachel's wedding and
she's just gonna suddenly move in with
her unannounced and become super tight
with all the girls yep instantly tell me
about Monica okay there's a lot of good
used to be fact so the jokes kind of
write themselves because she's this way
this is any group of overweight people a
large group of okay maybe not but these
jokes are gonna be really good
I fell in love with Chandler eventually
Chandler is one of the friends right it
sounds like a lot of these friends are
actually lovers so well maybe we should
tell the show lovers their friends the
wisecracking sarcastic guy Russo he's
always making the other friends laugh
they will never laugh a little crazy it
is when he stopped to think about it so
are there any other love friends are
there any other friends
well there's also Joey who's Chandler's
roommate and what's his deal
well he's dumb and he likes food but
he's not fast so that's it no he also
really likes sleeping with women like if
he could sleep with over 50 women during
the course of the show that yeah well
next up there's Phoebe well very early
on we're gonna find out that her mother
committed suicide to Jesus so then
Phoebe was taken care of by this albino
guy and then he killed himself Wow kind
of balance out the show together most of
the time they hang out in a coffee shop
they very rarely go to work and other
than that they just hang out in their
giant beautiful apartments they're in
their mid-twenties but they have giant
beautiful apartments that's right so
this takes place in like a small town or
New York City they must all have like
really high-powered jobs well Joey is a
struggling actor Rachel works in a
coffee shop
Monica works in a restaurant Chandler
has a job he plays the guitar
interesting and I'm guessing since it's
in New York there's gonna be a lot of
diversity that's all she wrote that's
all I wrote that's fun oh let's not play
with it wait do that again
[Laughter]
I'm low level no name actors how come
well to be completely honest a show like
this will last one maybe two seasons so
this way we know we're never gonna have
to pay a lot of money for actors fair
enough that's smart
[Music]
Walking Dead subscribe and you can check
out screener and calm for all the latest
movie TV news thanks for watching we'll
see you next time my brother actually
just texted me a video from this guy
yeah you wanted me to watch every the
funny ass money's another effort man oh
such great points about my favorite [ __ ]
is evidence in New York so they'll be
ethnically diverse they're all white
yeah I mean judging I've been like two
black characters in this show and a few
other like Black Codes like co-stars in
an episode but like two main black guest
stars one reoccurring and one in another
episode both love interests
objectification yeah yeah oh I know
there's the guy who actually hired
Chandler towards the end of the season
when he was going through his internship
yeah
as far as it goes judging by the journey
you've taken me on through the show I
mean this see pretty spot-on yeah this
is hilarious I mean it started off at
first I was like no is this gonna be
funny and then pretty soon it just got
hilarious yeah javis Bailey we brought
you a really interesting guy
no people becoming paleontologists I
loved his back and forth that he created
here uh
I mean this looks like the kind of thing
that he probably puts together all the
way himself maybe there's someone a
whole t camera but that could just be a
editing program effect to make it have a
little handheld effect yeah I asked that
way it feels like but like he he wrote
this very tight like this is tightly
well done so I'm very impressed with the
way how he handles this video man well
it's very knowing about the show even
down to the like the clapper thing first
I was like what do they go and then I
read the friends
I love his comment about Chandler in
this episode because it's true people
are always like Chandler is the funny
one Chandler is the funny one and it's
kind of weird to say when I think this
is one of the best ensembles in
television history especially in terms
of a comedy cast like there's someone on
patreon and Barry Bullock I've talked
with quite a bit about friends I was
tell him like I love how the show
doesn't really have a lead like they're
all the lead characters in here man it
wasn't even intended to be that way so
you say the counter is the funny one but
but they're all funny you know but
writers but fun but the character
Chandler is supposed to be the funny one
in the group he's gonna be like it
suppresses emotions with humor I started
to think back like have I ever seen
third sounds really characters laugh at
his jokes rare he's always making these
like insanely sarcastic comments but
rarely are people actually laughing at
his jokes and the show itself one of the
things that I find kind of funny when I
when I look back on the show or whenever
I usually like once here and have like
re watching the whole thing on my own
time I notice there's a lot of gay jokes
maybe for being a 90s there's a lot like
in terms of like masculinity yeah every
time anything remotely gay happens the
dude characters yeah yeah yeah so
there's that even though I think one of
the head writers and creators is a gay
guy and you know one thing I find kind
of surprising too is how sexual the show
has always been has always been so many
sex jokes and the show came out in like
the mid-90s that sex was invented
towards the latter part of the seasons
they would be more blunt in terms of how
they would actually talk about sex you
know you know
they just say the word sex or akanda bad
back then it was like a lot of you know
hints at it either add or saying they
sleep together a lie you know they slept
together did you sleep with her for the
end they started getting a lot more
vulgar and more clear-cut about their
sex comedy in there and there is a lot
of fat jokes in there though John that
is a repetitive joke that I did think
gets pretty old after a while
especially in the last parts of the
seasons where it's like I get it
Monica used to be fat you're running out
of comedy material for her biggest
associations with friends is watching it
with you and just the moments in which
those jokes to pop up and you would just
go she's fat that really is the amount
of a lot I am so glad he brought up that
point about Phoebe's dark past yes
because that is so true she is such a
dark past you know because of the kind
of show it is they didn't manage to make
it funny but there would be jokes about
like suicide or whatever and I forget
what specific episode it was but if you
forgot to do something and she was like
well you know my mom killed herself look
you can't keep pulling that card Phoebe
like something like that so it sounds
dark when I say it in that kind of
context but in the show it was really
funny okay so it does make me wonder how
that pitch meeting went down because
this is by no means a high stakes
concept yeah and if you know the
characters are very likeable but I've
seen even those like blog posts or on
Cermak net about how the friends cast is
really some of the meanest characters on
television and everybody yeah that's
true they are they are all jerks to each
other in a lot of ways you know which is
something you can find with a lot of
television and movies actually was like
oh well they were actually really big
dicks to one another yeah ribbing is a
much bigger part of on-screen and
friendship yeah ribbing to such a degree
like Rachel in the early part of the
season was kind of a meaner character
but as she grew she became nicer that's
true about the never wearing a bra thing
though I mean that's funny you pointed
out because I talked a lot about getting
nipple chills on this channel and whole
show Jason definitely had a lot of
nipple shields while filming in that
cold ass studio on the Warner Brothers
lot man
yeah times are like peaking right there
yeah I didn't want to point it out ever
but yeah that's true it's true this is a
really funny video so thank you Ryan
over at Screen Rant for putting this
together thank you Michael B for
requesting this and Michael B is a guy
who has a channel called Omni one media
it's a fantastic channel I'm constantly
telling people that you got to go check
it out because he is someone who can be
a huge youtuber just get this falling a
little bit bigger you'll see what I'm
talking about he watches videos he
really knows his stuff he's great at
commentary he's even on the Stardust app
as well you guys should follow him as
soon as you can there's a link in the
description box for him this guy and I
we talked throughout the week and we
have long messages back and forth with
one another I'm sorry that the last
video request got blocked on YouTube he
didn't have a chance to see it that's it
we gotta find our Sonny a lot of our
block videos end up going up on our
patreon so hopefully we can find a way
to get that back and put it up on our
patron page just for you I mean it got
20,000 views before it got blocked so
that's your fault man two days of not
being blocked before so you know it's on
you pay your notifications Michael we
did the video yeah I'm still sorry
anyway guys what's your favorite friends
episode it's really easy to narrow down
there's only ten seasons you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us on
patreon weekly Q&A is TV show reaction
watch along as he does music video
coverage plenty of goodies we offer over
there do it today